Bobo you know tomorrow's Father's Day
right and I expect that she won't give
me something nice I'm not sure what I
was expecting for Father's Day maybe
like a really expensive watch or you
know a Ferrari rental Halloweekend well
you know daddy knows that you've been on
your superhero thing lately so I figured
we could be superheroes go home we
decorate these cake I thought it'd be a
good idea for us to like make superhero
costumes you know bone exercise I think
I'd be insulted the whole time do you
love daddy Emory does this thing and I
feel really bad well she'll look at here
and she'll be like mommy's my favorite
it's funny how I think you like mommy
more than you like me
I'm just saying so I guess like if I had
a question why you like mommy more do
you like me you being dismissive here
does this thing where he goes up to her
and he'll just snuggle up with her you
kiss her like this you see how she lets
me do it she doesn't let him do that so
both of us are your favorite no when
everybody said I'm not her favorite I
want a surprise like look this is how
the hierarchy goes it's God mommy
children the dog that dead spider in the
corner now underneath that is daddy
that's why I have today is Father's Day
daddy is it my face because I have a
stupid face is this something that I can
do better
like can I be a better father ice cream
or cookies I mean sometimes it even
feels like you know mommy better that
you won't be what you think black and
yellow so what do you think about
Father's Day be like Father's Day no why
it's for daddy though okay let me let me
let you finish your cracker first okay
you know it's like I only have feelings
no more she say don't hurt me a part of
me died a long time ago
so quick Q&A I want to see how well you
know me what's daddy's favorite color
he's actually black what's daddy's
favorite food I actually hate spinach
[Music]
I'm asking the question you know when
you sit on a toilet for a long time
and then like your legs go numb well
that's my heart ain't no joke
just a lot of her village I don't
understand why you don't like me I'm
likable look at the smile look miss you
faked her not me you know I don't feel
like you're being very nice to me right
now
you're making me say show me how you
fight you fight the children's no it's
must occur
[Music]
come on bring it on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know father with Danny's favorite
food
I don't know how know Amy came to be
emery's favorite I mean yeah she nursed
her and held her in her womb for nine
months and was the first person to hold
her and was the first person to kiss her
boo-boos and Wow
okay no idea what she'll like me down
but still damn it I deserve what the
Father's Day gift thank you baby this is
the best Father's Day ever what yeah
Mikey
[Music]
yeah